[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález un ex
presidente y un ex ministro de hacienda
disputará la segunda vuelta presidencial
en costa rica
estamos hablando de josé maría figueres
del partido liberación nacional quien ya
gobernó el país entre 1994 y 1998 y que
no obtuvo el 27,2 por ciento de los
votos figueres se enfrentará al
exministro rodrigo chávez quien fue
encargado de la cartera de hacienda
durante el año 2020 durante la
administración del saliente presidente
carlos alvarado chávez obtuvo el 16 6
por ciento de los votos quienes son
estos dos elegidos para esta segunda
vuelta y como se va a configurar el mapa
político de costa rica- de cara a esa
segunda ronda veamos más detalles en el
siguiente informe
fin de la primera vuelta electoral en
costa rica que dejó como favorito al ex
presidente josé maría figueres la opción
del partido de liberación nacional
ni la pandemia fue capaz de doblegar
de nuestro pueblo
uno más la valentía
y el amor a la patria
responsabilidad de sacar adelante a
nuestro país en segundo lugar el
economista rodrigo chávez logró llevar a
su partido progreso social democrático a
enfrentar el balotaje a pesar de que los
sondeos lo situaban en cuarto lugar
vamos a una segunda ronda
el partido nuevo el más joven de esta
campaña vamos a la segunda ronda
pero vamos a dejar atrás los rejuegos el
conflicto la confrontación estéril y les
ruego que nos aboquemos todos juntos a
pesar de la amplia oferta con 25
partidos el abstencionismo marcó un
récord de más del 40 por ciento debido a
la insatisfacción ya un gran índice de
indecisión entre los ciudadanos lo que
uno espera que el país mejore pero en
vez de mejorar se empeora porque todos
prometen pero no hacen nada ahora
después de que ninguno de los candidatos
alcanzará el 40 por ciento necesario
para ganar en la primera ronda los dos
aspirantes a la presidencia se
enfrentarán en una segunda vuelta el 3
de abril y quien finalmente gane tendrá
que enfrentar retos como la pobreza con
un índice del 26,2 por ciento en 2020 el
alto desempleo y la paralización de los
índices de desarrollo debido a la
pandemia acciones de largo plazo para
volver a ganarse la confianza del pueblo
costarricense
pues ya lo ven ustedes 3 de abril será
esa fecha clave de esa segunda vuelta
que definirá a quién llevará las riendas
de costa rica con importantes retos como
veíamos muchos retos en términos
sociales tiene este país por delante
pero cómo se van a acomodar entonces las
piezas del escenario político
costarricense de cara a esa segunda
vuelta que balance se puede hacer del
desempeño de los nuevos partidos en esta
primera ronda quienes fueron las grandes
sorpresas por su buen desempeño y lo
contrario por su mal rendimiento en las
urnas que se puede decir de la alta
abstención y cómo quedó compuesto
entonces la asamblea legislativa allí en
costa rica el balance de esta primera
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
y parlamentarias en este país
centroamericano es nuestro tema de
debate en france 24 para analizar este
tema saludamos en san jose a paola
nájera abarca ella es diputada electa
por el partido progreso social
democrático psd también está con
nosotros también desde la capital
costarricense
montserrat ruiz es la diputada electa
por el partido liberación nacional en
este debate también participan ustedes
televidentes pueden participar a través
de comentarios y preguntas a través de
nuestras redes sociales no se encuentran
en facebook en instagram y en twitter
estamos como arroba france24 guión bajo
s y arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal nuestra etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 esperamos todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas sobre todo
con toda nuestra audiencia de france 24
en centroamérica particularmente allí en
costa rica que nos comenten y nos digan
cómo les parecieron el rendimiento de
estos candidatos a lo largo de esta
jornada electoral el pasado fin de
semana allí en costa rica comienzo
entonces con paola en san jose
preguntándole como punto de partida de
este debate el balance que hace usted de
esta jornada electoral del domingo unos
comicios importantes para los
costarricenses cuáles son sus
impresiones de esta primera ronda que se
puede destacar que quedó sobre la mesa y
que queda de cara a la segunda vuelta
un saludo caluroso hasta bogotá colombia
un gusto enorme estar acá gracias por
utilizar nuestras elecciones como un
ejemplo para
utilizarlo para el análisis el del
balance que nosotros hacemos a raíz de
las elecciones vividas nos demuestran
que el principal red pero efectivamente
es poder conquistar aquella población
desencantada
como ustedes bien mencionaron en la nota
40 punto 65 por ciento de nuestro caudal
electoral no asistió a las urnas pese a
la amplia variedad
25 personas postularon su nombre sin
embargo no logramos más bien este
aumentaron los índices de
te desencanto y de abstencionismo
entonces ese es el primer reto que
nosotros que nosotros vemos por otro
lado nos queda una gran satisfacción de
saber que quienes sí asistieron a las
urnas lograron ver en el partido
político más nuevo más fresco una opción
para el cambio definitivamente la
trayectoria internacional técnica y
profesional de nuestro candidato ha dado
seguridad y una señal importante de que
podemos representar esa fuerza necesaria
para sacar a costa rica a adelante en
esta etapa
diputada montserrat ruiz también allí en
la ciudad de san jose sus impresiones
balance de esta jornada electoral del
fin de semana en su país en costa rica
este es nuestro punto de partida para el
debate
bueno muchísimas gracias por la
invitación saludos a la bella ciudad de
bogotá de colombia
para nosotros un honor estar también hoy
conversando sobre nuestro proceso
democrático que es un ejemplo a nivel
mundial en efecto tuvimos un alto
porcentaje de abstencionismo más se dio
una campaña con 25 candidatos donde pues
el pueblo costarricense hoy decide que
en su mayoría es el partido de
liberación nacional un partido con una
trayectoria de más de 70 años el que
sigue imperando en el electorado
nacional hoy con propuestas hoy con un
candidato un líder a nivel mundial
respaldado y también con un equipo que
suma experiencia en su trayectoria y que
suma el compromiso que necesita a costa
rica esta jornada nos demuestra que
necesitamos seguir cultivando criterios
realmente valiosos para poder sostener
de lo de lo que tanto nosotros los
costarricenses nos enorgullecemos
no pues si se da una campaña atípica
dentro de no solo una pandemia que sigue
azotando nos y que pues la gente todavía
le tiene temor y pues que todavía
seguimos teniendo víctimas de la misma
sino también atípica en el sentido de
que en las últimas dos elecciones había
una polarización de discusiones que en
esta vez creo y celebro realmente que
todos los candidatos tenían la claridad
de que costa rica lo que necesita hoy es
empleo y activación económica y la
valoración de las propuestas fueron
fundamentales bueno quiero que hagamos
balance de la primero de puntos
generales de estos comicios luego nos
vamos a
poner a hacer el análisis en cuanto a
los candidatos y las posibles
formaciones que puedan surgir de cara a
esa segunda vuelta pero qué mensaje
manda el electorado costarricense
diputada nájera habiendo elegido para
esa segunda vuelta como lo mencionaba la
diputada ruiz
candidato de un partido tradicional de
la escena política costarricense y un
candidato de un partido completamente
nuevo dentro de un espectro de 25
candidatos en un país pequeño en cuanto
a la población como es costa rica la
oferta era muy grande y tal parece que
salen dos opciones o dos ofertas de país
muy diferentes que lecturas a usted la
lectura que nosotros hacemos es que
efectivamente
nuestra población a grito nos pide un
cambio pero un cambio real que
evidentemente no ha podido encontrar en
fuerzas políticas que llamamos
tradicionales y se da la oportunidad que
una nueva fuerza política muy técnica
con criterios incluso de selección de
sus candidatos muy diferentes a lo que
siempre se ha acostumbrado realizar
dentro de los partidos sea esta opción
nueva se le da la oportunidad a este
nuevo grupo de poder representar esa
segunda fuerza política que va a una
segunda ronda por primera vez
participando de unos comicios logramos
realizar una fuerza parlamentaria es la
tercera en
en tamaño y además asistir a una segunda
ronda derrotando a al resto de partidos
que ya han repetido participación desde
hace muchas contiendas anteriores
entonces la frescura se ha marcado como
un como un punto importante muy bien
recibido y evidentemente satisface la
necesidad de esta población que pide a
gritos un cambio no sólo en la manera de
ser política sino en la manera en que
nosotros
representamos a dentro de un partido
político y diputada ruiz su percepción
sobre este tema un
electorado o unos ciudadanos
costarricenses como ampliando un poco lo
que dice la diputada nájera apostándole
por un cambio algo distinto o
apostándole a lo seguro a lo que ya
conocen y lo que han visto cómo funciona
y como no funciona cuál es su impresión
pero bueno más allá de un cambio costa
rica ya ha aprobado en los últimos ocho
años que el cambio no funciona
y hemos visto en los últimos 12 años
fuerzas partidarias partidos nuevos que
al final de cuentas terminan siempre en
la improvisación y agotando el sistema
democrático de nuestro país y el estado
social de derecho tanto así que por eso
el abstencionismo crece y yo considero
que eso termina siendo parte de este
fortalecimiento que se le sigue dando al
avance liberacionista de nuestro partido
como ese elemento no solo seguro sino
también innovador hoy somos la fracción
legislativa más grande y eso siempre ha
sido así en los últimos 20 años así que
consideramos que esta segunda ronda
esperábamos ganar en una primera
esperaba lastimosamente insisto ha sido
una jornada atípica electoral donde no
se podía hoy generar la forma de hacer
política de la cual estábamos
acostumbrados a aquellas reuniones a
aquellas plazas públicas grandes todo
donde se revelaba realmente el poder de
los ciudadanos al poder participar en
estos espacios
siderar yo considero y consideramos
desde nuestro partido que esto termina
siendo la grandiosa oportunidad de
seguir fortaleciendo no sólo la
liberación nacional sino a costa rica no
en un cambio en una transformación y en
un rescate es lo que necesita el país
hoy
diputada ruiz continuó con usted para
hacer la ronda a la inversa para cambiar
la dinámica hablemos de las formaciones
las coaliciones los avales que pueden
recibir por parte de de otros partidos
quienes pueden apoyar la candidatura de
figueres de cara a esa segunda vuelta en
que se van a apoyar ustedes para
conquistar ese voto decisivo para llegar
a la presidencia
figueres dijo que estaba
con sus puertas completamente abiertas
para que otros partidos políticos puedan
unirse a esa búsqueda de esa reforma del
país que desde su punto de vista quieren
los costarricenses pero yendo por un
camino seguro por un partido que ya
conocen de larga data en términos
políticos en quienes se pueden apoyar
quienes los pueden avalar a ustedes allí
bueno nosotros tenemos una ideología
socialdemócrata que en estos 70 años
hemos generado un sinfín de luchas
sociales que han fortalecido a una clase
media y a los sectores más vulnerables
del país hoy apelamos a todos aquellos
candidatos que salen de la contienda
este domingo y que hoy también forman
parte de la fracción hoy tenemos seis
partidos en la asamblea legislativa
apelamos a ese compromiso real de
rescatar costa rica con nuestras
propuestas y en con un elemento también
una variante importante y es que nuestro
líder es un líder conciliador es un
líder de diálogo es un líder
que puede sentarse en una mesa hoy a
negociar lo mejor que necesita este país
y apelando siempre al sentido de la
razonabilidad la defensa de mujeres de
jóvenes y de todos aquellos grupos que
hoy han sido invisibilizados también
y del otro lado de la moneda diputada
nájera que espera el candidato chávez
para esta segunda vuelta quienes pueden
apoyar esta candidatura un partido nuevo
fundado en el 2018 con poca trayectoria
en estos grandes escenarios de disputas
políticas de disputa del electorado pero
que ha logrado calar las muestras de los
votos así lo evidencian y esta segunda
posición en la en la preferencia de voto
así lo dicen pero la segunda ronda va a
estar difícil el escenario va a estar
muy reñido
así es es somos sumamente conscientes de
eso de que tanto como ocurrió en la
primera ronda el abstencionismo es el
principal reto a vencer en este sentido
tal como lo mencionó nuestro candidato
en su discurso
necesitamos hacer un llamado urgente a
todas esas personas que desde las
diferentes fuerzas políticas estamos
interesadas en sacar adelante a costa
rica eso nos va a permitir tender ese
puente ese interés la unión en este
objetivo único de sacar adelante el país
independientemente del color político es
el que nos mueve al recibir las
sanciones que no sólo desde los partidos
políticos estamos recibiendo sino desde
grupos importantes cámaras movimientos
sociales ya estamos recibiendo con el
objetivo de sacar adelante al país desde
un equipo técnico claramente demostrado
desde su trayectoria internacional y en
los diferentes espacios que el resto de
candidatos y hemos tenido la oportunidad
de realizar nosotros nos ofrecemos como
ese equipo sólido que de amalgamar las
otras fuerzas políticas y sociales
interesadas en el mismo objetivo de
sacar adelante estas la riqueza que
nosotros tenemos de ofrecernos como este
espacio donde nos vamos a unir una serie
de fuerzas para sacar adelante a costa
rica
diputada nájera diputada ruiz y creo que
vale la pena hablar de el tema de la
abstención lo mencionábamos superior al
40 por ciento el más alto en 60 años en
este país centroamericano que es el
ejemplo de la democracia en
centroamérica que reflexiones hacen
ustedes al respecto desprendiéndose un
poco de las consignas de sus partidos y
como ciudadanas y como mujeres en la
política del país que reflexión pueden
hacer de este 40 por ciento de
abstención fue por este gran abanico de
opciones que había en el tarjetón 25 en
total y la gente simplemente prefirió no
votar y esperar al segundo escenario
hay otros factores adicionales comienzo
con la diputada nájera para hacer la
ronda a la inversa
muchas gracias en realidad no creo que
se deba a la oferta que experimentamos
esta vez sino más bien a una serie de
factores desde el desencanto que ya se
trae por la queja constante de la
ciudadanía de la distancia que suele
haber entre el partido político y la
ciudadanía y principalmente la ausencia
de la satisfacción de las necesidades
para el buen vivir que es lo que sabemos
que todas las personas necesitamos
sabemos que efectivamente haciendo a un
lado la investidura y la representación
del partido político en el que yo del
que formo parte como una ciudadana
también puedo afirmar que ha habido una
serie de factores en el ambiente
político que ha desencantado a las
personas que ha mandado lastimosamente
la señal de que acá le damos a la gente
lo que necesita entonces esa es la razón
por la que nosotros decidimos dar un
paso adelante somos una serie de
personas que participamos por primera
vez en política electoral sin embargo
siempre hemos estado vinculados desde
nuestros espacios en la atención de
asuntos de carácter público entonces
esta vez nosotros hemos decidido ponerlo
al servicio de las personas
desligando nos un poco de de este tinte
político y creo que allí fue parte de la
ventaja que tuvimos de poder mandar la
señal de que somos fuimos un grupo de
ciudadanos como todos pero esta vez
decidimos dar el paso al frente
involucrándonos entonces creo que eso
eso ha marcado también un poco la
diferente diputada ruiz su impresión su
opinión sobre el tema de la abstención
tenemos más de 20 años de no dialogar
con el pueblo y eso es uno de los
factores
más
directos con respecto al abstencionismo
costa rica- de sus políticos dejamos de
negociar con aquellas personas que hoy
dejaron de creer en que realmente es la
política y en la democracia la que puede
sustentar el beneficio y el bienhacer de
todos los costarricenses en este caso
también creo que es un tema educativo
creo que tenemos que reforzar las
primeras infancias en procesos
democráticos y cívicos para que empiecen
a encantarse con estos espacios y en
efecto hemos estado participando
hoy tanto mujeres como hombres que hemos
explicados a ciertos caminos de interés
de sectores específicos en estos en esta
no usted si este portafolio que tenemos
hoy para poder desde el ejecutivo y
legislativo
cambiar cambiar y seguir incentivando a
todos aquellos jóvenes para qué puedan
hoy salir nos dimos cuenta es una
particularidad también en estas
elecciones que la juventud no salió a
votar y eso es complicado esto es
peligroso mucho más en un país tan
democrático como el nuestro y donde
tenemos también pues hoy una una
pirámide inversa de personas adultas
mayores de que indistintamente van
saliendo de ciertos enfoques y no están
muy participando el llamado también a la
obtención de vemos se daría en la medida
en que podamos disminuir la brecha
generacional e integrar a jóvenes y
mujeres dentro de los procesos
electorales de nuestro país importante
la votación de los jóvenes es importante
hacer ese llamado a ejercer ese derecho
al voto teniendo en cuenta las
circunstancias que se están dando allí
paso a preguntarles ahora por un algo
que me llamó la atención y es el
desempeño del partido de acción
ciudadana pac que es el partido
oficialista es el del presidente carlos
alvarado que resultó muy castigado que
reflexión se puede hacer que análisis se
hace de eso diputada ruiz
bueno el par compartido réplica yo hace
ocho años fue un partido
con una posición en ese momento
atractiva para una apuesta de un
electorado que nuevamente teníamos
claridad venía desgastado de este
proceso de no diálogo de este proceso de
la inserción de juventudes y que se vio
atractivo interesante para el electorado
y pues que hoy está teniendo las
consecuencias de sus acciones con falta
de liderazgo con falta de equipo de
trabajo con falta de capacidad de poder
sentar a todos los sectores a la mesa y
una inexperiencia completa técnica
también sin estructura eso es importante
y termina siendo una apuesta más que hoy
resulta pues ser castigado
dentro de este voto ciudadano
diputada será la misma pregunta a sus
impresiones sobre este desempeño del
pack que cierra un capítulo de gobierno
carlos alvarado al frente de la
presidencia de costa rica y ahora su
partido pues tuvo un mal desempeño en
estas votaciones y no está dentro de los
dentro de los partidos de preferencia de
voto de los ciudadanos esto que dice que
lectura se puede hacer la distancia
nuevamente que
diferentes espacios sea ha atribuido al
partido acción ciudadana entre el
gobierno y efectivamente la población en
distintos espacios se le hizo el reclamo
de inclusive cerrar la información en la
rendición de cuentas el involucramiento
con los medios de comunicación y eso
sinceramente fue algo que resintió mucho
no sólo al gremio periodista sino a la
democracia porque se sentían algunos
tintes
autoritaristas dady y faltos de querer
involucrar a las personas quienes
terminan convirtiéndose en los usuarios
finales de los servicios que brinda el
estado y además son los receptores de
las decisiones que desde el gobierno se
toma por otro lado un elemento curvo y
coyuntural que fue tener que gobernar en
medio de la pandemia algo que demostró
alguna debilidad en toda el andamiaje
público sin embargo y por muchos
intentos que se hizo sabemos que ya
había una crisis económica y política
que se venía
desencadenando de modo que podemos
afirmar que la crisis cayó sobre una
crisis entonces fue un elemento
coyuntural y además de desempeño que
involucraba también la falta de diálogo
que fue algo que se le reclamó muchísimo
a este gobierno alvarado sin embargo es
importante poder ver esto para cada una
de las fuerzas políticas de manera
sincera que tenemos el interés de sacar
adelante al país podrá reflexionar sobre
ellas para no volverlas a comer y por
último para cerrar este análisis de
balance de la jornada del domingo que se
puede decir de la candidatura de
fabricio alvarado que en las elecciones
pasadas llegó hasta la segunda ronda
tuvo una votación muy cerrada con el
actual mandatario fue una presidencia
que tuvo perdón a las elecciones
presidenciales que tuvo en vilo a el
continente entero
con una final de fotofinish y estuvo
siempre en la segunda posición de
preferencia de voto de acuerdo a las
encuestas y ahora lo vemos fuera de esa
segunda ronda lo vemos en un tercer
lugar diputada ruiz sus opiniones su
impresión sobre esta esta candidatura
que se quedó en esta primera fase claro
mi apreciación es que el electorado
costarricense por lo menos una parte no
el fuerte de nuestro liberacionista
termina siempre escogiendo partidos
nuevos en este caso el señor fabricio
alvarado estaba cobijado hace cuatro
años por el partido de restauración
nacional el cual pues segmentar a lo
largo de estos cuatro años ya en
gobierno el señor funda su partido y
empieza pues a fortalecer no sólo las
bases que ya tenía sino el ingreso de
otras
el fenómeno aquí se da no sólo en
procesos del gran área metropolitana del
país sino también el fortalecimiento del
partido también democrático el que
representa la mi compañera paola con
respecto al poder fortalecer la
territorialidad que creo que era el
fuerte del señor fabricio al parado y
que probablemente por él no tuvo ahí el
enfoque claro como sí lo tuvo el otro
contrincante
diputada nájera hablemos de los temas
centrales para este para lo que resta de
estas campañas de cara a esa segunda
vuelta en esta primera ronda no hubo un
tema claro no hubo un tema transversal
que marcará estas campañas pero tal
parece que la economía el tema económico
va tomando poco a poco más fuerza para
esta segunda vuelta a parte de la
economía que otros temas ven ustedes
destacados para esta segunda ronda que
puedan empezar a mover los candidatos en
sus campañas en sus intervenciones o que
los mismos ciudadanos empiezan a
cuestionar sobre qué planes se van a
poner en marcha durante los gobiernos
que puedan llegar al país
muy relacionado con el tema de las
extensionismo por la decepción el
desencanto de la ciudadanía
evidentemente es el tema corrupción
entonces cuáles opciones anticorrupción
desde la dpt y desde las agendas de los
partidos políticos estamos ofreciendo a
la ciudadanía es fundamental y eso no
nos cabe la menor duda es es un tema
recurrente en medios en redes sociales
entonces ese es un tema vital de atender
por otro lado también ligado al
combate a la corrupción es la creación
de la confianza si evidentemente
nosotros queremos conquistar participar
y atraer a una población que en
que no quiere salir a votar la
generación de confianza mediante la
participación real de la ciudadanía es
sumamente importante este es punto que
nunca no cabe duda que nosotros
necesitamos retomar desde los diferentes
espacios durante campaña durante
gobierno eso es vital por otro lado el
apagón educativo que nosotros tuvimos a
la luz de la pandemia que que seguimos
viviendo es un punto clave no solamente
para el desarrollo entonces esos son
algunos de los temas que nosotros vemos
fundamentales de atender en esta segunda
ronda para esta segunda con en la otra
orilla diputada ruiz que temas de usted
trascendentales importantes para esta
segunda ronda la generación de empleo
las propuestas concretas en generación
de empleo donde puedan todas las
personas costarricenses hoy generar sus
ingresos y tener una vida digna debemos
volver a dignificar a las costas debemos
volver a dignificar a la territorialidad
de costa rica y eso sólo se hace con
propuestas
estas concretas nuestro plan de gobierno
hoy tiene propuestas reales que vienen
no sólo sustancialmente
concretadas en materia de financiamiento
y demás sino hasta con números de que
estaríamos generando más de 200 mil
empleos en 24 meses y eso es lo que se
necesita eso es lo que se necesita para
salir de una crisis fiscal que nos tiene
agobiados no sólo por una pandemia sino
ya en una pre pandemia que veníamos en
ese debacle económico así que esto es lo
que necesita escuchar la gente y lo que
necesita vivir la gente propuestas y
propuestas reales con agendas
construidas con los mismos sectores que
desde lo cual nosotros nos hemos
encargado en el último año de estar
reunidos con diferentes sectores
cooperativos solidaristas asociaciones
asociaciones 18 y cámaras para poder
construir realmente esta generación de
empleo y de ingreso que necesita el país
llama tan pocos minutos para terminar el
programa quiero cerrar hablando
en torno al tema de los votantes
potenciales veíamos una
un foco en estas campañas para esta
primera ronda sobre todo en las zonas
urbanas creo que se le dio especial
atención a los habitantes del valle
central san jose de cartago alajuela y
la zona rural y las zonas de las costas
como menciona la diputada ruiz pueden
ser claves para esta segunda vuelta y
también algunos segmentos de la sociedad
costarricense por ejemplo lo estamos
mencionando los jóvenes y las mujeres a
quienes creen ustedes que se debe hacer
foco para atraer más votos para captar
una mayor participación y para
finalmente hacerse con los votos
suficientes para llegar a la presidencia
diputada ruiz
bueno las mujeres las mujeres hoy
representamos el 50 por ciento de la
población costarricense y del electorado
y hoy somos nosotras las que estamos
encabezando números de informalidad
números de pobreza números de
precarización laboral y somos nosotras
las que también hoy podríamos estar
generando un gran margen de activación
económica y enfocamos realmente estas
propuestas de las cuales hemos estado
planteando desde el partido liberación
nacional hacia ellas es importante la
territorialidad la descentralización
también de éxitos para poder llegar a
todo tipo de mujeres a las mujeres de
todas las edades mujeres de las costas
mujeres mujeres del agro mujeres de
pequeñas y medianas emprendedoras y por
supuesto a la juventud una juventud
deseosa de empleo una juventud deseosa
de eliminación de esta brecha
tecnológica de que también se pueda
sustentar el trabajo en ciudades
inteligentes esta es parte del valioso
electorado que debemos y por supuesto
sectores cooperativos cámaras y demás
que siempre han sido
y enfoques socialdemócratas de nuestro
valioso partido
diputada e nájera su opinión
también coincido con la compañera en el
sentido de que nosotros tenemos deudas
históricas con la mujer autonomía
económica un tema importantísimo que es
el cuido la educación ahí nosotros
debemos atender esas necesidades y
generar las propuestas durante durante
campaña para captar a ésta a esta
población por otro lado juventud
juventud para poder generar los espacios
dirigidos por por esta misma juventud
que tiene sus propias necesidades
habladas en su propio lenguaje porque yo
siempre digo que el adulto suele ser
como el traductor de las necesidades del
joven necesitamos espacios reales donde
el joven hable con su propio lenguaje se
empodere pueda generar sus propuestas de
solución y evidentemente salirnos de
éste
del valle central a ir hacia nuestras
zonas rurales y volver los ojos a
nuestros grupos que principalmente
agricultores por ejemplo la provincia
que yo represento cartago una provincia
meramente agrícola este es uno de los
grupos principales con los que nosotros
conversamos para poder atraer y generar
soluciones reales y para esta esta etapa
y para poder desarrollarlas durante o
bien persona diputará diputada paola
nájera y a la diputada montserrat ruiz
les agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros en el programa en el debate de
france 24 haber puesto en perspectiva su
balance de esta primera ronda de las
elecciones presidenciales en costa rica
y como queda entonces configurado el
panorama político de cara a esa segunda
vuelta que será el 3 de abril esta fecha
es fundamental de allí saldrá entonces
quién va a ser el nuevo presidente de
este país centroamericano el ejemplo
electoral y democrático allí en la
región de centroamérica y el 8 de mayo
se espera que entonces asuma la
presidencia el nuevo mandatario ustedes
pueden seguir haciendo todo tipo de
preguntas y comentarios a través de las
redes sociales y por su sigan en
sintonía de la programación de france 24
siga con nosotros
[Música]